Early versions of Android
don't have cursor loaders.
Instead, the cursor adapter requeried
the database on the main UI thread,
when data from a content
provider changed.
This caused frame rate
drops in many applications.
The first answer is a definite yes.
We noted how things like async
tasks are bound to the UI.
So something as little
as an orientation change
could cause the query to complete
after the activity stops.
So that's another definite yes.
The cursor being tied to the activity
also means that the data would
generally have to be requeried
when the screen rotates, so
there are definitely disadvantages.